I don't know anything about your husband
I swear to God
so wait no to know I'm doing what I'm
doing with this book this is exactly why
I didn't come here the drama surrounding
Jenelle Evans just took a turn the 27
year olds storming off the Teen Mom
reunion set after host message AB
confronted her about some anti Colin
Kaepernick posts she shared on social
media last year Nessa is Colin's
girlfriend I posted hateful comments on
social media about my family about my
man Colin Kaepernick you knew that I've
seen him yes you did Jenelle denied you
posted the comments I've never seen that
please understand something my man uses
his platform to peacefully protest
systemic oppression in this country so
specifically police brutality against
black people okay men women and children
are dying wrongfully dying and people
who are doing this are not being held
accountable
Jenelle teared up and accused Nessa of
steering the reunion off-topic this is
about this is about my story mom I
wanted to tell you want to bring up
fewer issues it's been a rocky time for
Jenelle on TV recently cut ties with her
and has no plans to cover her story in
the upcoming season
oh god the news comes after Jenelle's
husband David Eason allegedly shot and
killed their dog did get you should be
MTV ended their relationship with David
over a year ago after he posted a number
of homophobic and transphobic tweets
as for Janelle and David's future a
source says they are still an item and
Janelle has been telling close friends
they are considering marriage counseling
what are we gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]